he is the 27 year old Democratic mayor
of Stockton California please look at
his honor Michael Tubbs so you are
America's youngest mayor of a city over
a hundred thousand is that right
I tried to grow the beard so I looked a
little bit yeah it's true and how's that
going now Stockton California is where
roughly near Sacramento between
Sacramento San Francisco is the 12th
largest city in the state about 300,000
people 300,000 people hundred 23,000
people you're in charge of that with
other people helping yes of course
and what's I mean I'm not familiar with
the area that much is it a conservative
area is it it's actually a real mix the
Christian Science Monitor or the article
about how in these parts and times
Stockton seems to be figuring it out so
about 40% of the population actually
voted for the president 60% didn't it
the city is also incredibly diverse so
we're about 40 percent Latino 20% Asian
12% African American so we have a
microcosm of the country in terms of
race but also in terms of political
ideologies which makes governing very
interesting
I left that very you're doing some
interesting things in government I mean
you have something called universal
basic income that you it's a pilot
program right you bi they call it but
it's basically it's a fancy way of
saying we're gonna give some people free
money but with interest how's that
working out do they like free money well
in Alaska which has a permanent dividend
fund with the Eastern Band of Cherokee
Indians of course people are saying this
is a good thing but what's been
interesting is doing the research and
finding out that this program this idea
is as old as this nation itself that
Thomas Paine was calling for this an
agrarian revolution dr. King was
speaking about this before he was
assassinated and this is in place of
social programs like instead of food
stamps and stuff like that you're gonna
get just money and in my mind I think
we've enhanced a social safety net I
think right now with the programs we
have it helps stabilize some people but
people are still struggling I think the
misnomer here is that it's rewarding
people for sloth for being slothful but
I would imagine some would take
advantage but but the majority of poor
people are working that's we have that
term right well we have to do something
I'm just I'm just my job to question yes
sir
so I mean Joe Biden talks about how the
fact that it's not just having a job
economically it's it's dignity it's
having something to do all day what do
people do if they don't have jobs and
that that really is the crux of what
we're gonna have to deal with in this
country right is that robots are taking
all the jobs Automation you know they're
just not gonna be enough jobs for the
people well I think yes both so on the
idea of dignity of work my moms when the
most dignified people I know and she was
single she worked extremely hard and I
don't think there's anything inherently
dignified I'm working 14 hours a day and
still being depressed in avenues idly
right sitting around watching card
sharks you know but but but to your
point I think with the current went into
Americans today can afford one file and
our emergency imagine what happens when
there is automation and people are
displaced so we're piling this and
Stockton because we're saying that right
now let's talk about the economic system
whilst preparing folks for the jobs that
don't exist yet and and you also want to
as long as you're passing out money if I
get some of yours before I leave no it's
it's happened before I was very scared
about Mitt Romney it doesn't look too
good now but no you you also have a
program I think where you would give a
stipend right to the people you identify
is the most likely to commit murders in
the city so that they are induced not to
do that and there is precedent for that
we did that in Iraq we bribed the Sunnis
during the Iraq war don't shoot us shoot
them and it worked
people like money I resent being
compared to it stock can be compared to
Iraq but I would say the program I'm
just converting into a program but the
progress is interesting because it's not
just giving money but the money happens
after six months of intensive case
management their program is called
advanced piece and it's based off the
officer there were safety enrichment so
Sacramento is wearing their program as
well we're starting this summer and for
the other cities are looking at doing it
because the idea is that we're paying
$400,000 a year at cities for every
homicide and every shooting not even now
they're measuring the amount of trauma
you cannot you could identify who the
most likely people you know who the bad
people are the bad guys who are
committing the crime
and they tend not to if they have a
stipend
well the stipends apart so it's a
stipend that's also intensive case
management it's cognitive behavioral
therapy so helping deal with trauma is
transformed to travel but it's really
the crux is there really relationship in
seven days a week communication and also
like mapping so sitting down with your
coach I figured out how they go from A
to B and also the stipends after six
months and it's a fellowships we don't
just get it that's actually comes with
strings you have to do things for it so
it's almost like a job can you get the
stipend money I'm the free money I'm
just so what what is your biggest
problem there in in your city because we
we see cities you know we've had mayor's
on this show before and they seem to be
the ones who they're closest to real
problems they're not like the people in
Washington who can not do anything they
have to deal with stuff what what do you
have to deal with on a day to day basis
well the biggest issue in in Stockton is
poverty
20% of our populations in poverty but I
would argue another 25% or at least one
paycheck away and with poverty you see
things like violence and educational
attainment and in California with
housing costs rising and wages not we
have folks who are able to afford
housing so we're taking the long and
short term approach on the long term we
just launched a program called the
Stockton scholars which would make CSU
tuition free for the vast majority of
students in our public and our largest
public school system for any Democrat
why not Democrats run on repealing the
Trump tax cut which is a trillion and a
half dollars mostly to the rich you
could easily afford College for every
person in the country for that absent
let's do it
[Applause]